this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
for years now we've been recommending
the MacBook Air for users who need a
premium portable and reliable macbook
for simple tasks like web browsing video
streaming typing and using basic apps
but in the past year the iPad pro has
been getting a whole lot better thanks
to the release of iPad OS and general
software improvements and from the looks
of it the iPad pro is gonna get even
better in the coming months so in this
video we're gonna see if it actually
makes sense to buy an iPad pro for basic
computing tasks instead of the MacBook
Air
now while the MacBook Air hasn't really
changed in the last year the iPad pro
has changed a lot mainly in terms of
software support but before we get into
that let's take a look at the general
differences between the two starting
with the price the iPad pro retails for
$800 but is currently on sale for 735
dollars on Amazon and the MacBook Air
retails for $1,100 while also being on
sale for a thousand and 36 bucks so you
can save around 300 dollars by going
with the iPad pro and to make it more
like a laptop we added the bridge pro
keyboard which is the overall winner of
our recent best keyboard cases
comparison video which you can check out
at the end of this one that keyboard
case is currently on sale for $100 on
Amazon and it really makes a
night-and-day difference if you're
trying to use your iPad pro like a
laptop Bridge is also coming out with
their Pro Plus keyboard which actually
packs a trackpad so hit that subscribe
button below if you want to see us
review that very soon using the Bridge
Pro keyboard case is as simple as
sliding your iPad pro onto the hinge and
connecting it using bluetooth now you've
got a solid premium in aluminum laptop
replacement with the bridge pros row of
convenient iOS shortcut keys at the top
12 months of battery life and a USB C
port for charging the iPad pros display
is 11 inches quite a bit smaller than
the 13-inch display on the MacBook Air
but it's got a few perks which I'll
mention in a minute but of course you
can get the 12 point 9 inch iPad pro for
$200 more if you'd like the benefit of
the Bridge Pro keyboard case is that
it's one of the only ones that allows
you to adjust the angle of the display
anywhere from 0 to 180 degrees even
we're sold in the MacBook Air now before
we get into comparing things like the
displays battery life and speakers I
want to give you guys a sneak peek at
one of the ways the iPad pro has greatly
improved in recent months and that's
software support I've personally used
Squarespace our sponsor for this video
to create a website from a wife's
cleaning business with no prior web
making experience at all and in the past
couple of months
the Squarespace app for iOS has been
greatly optimized for the iPad pro
allowing you to edit anything in
everything on your custom website that
includes changing settings like the
built-in SEO tools or customizing blocks
of text and images and easily
rearranging them with drag-and-drop
support so you no longer need a laptop
or a computer for web making because of
how simple it is on the iPad pro so
whether you choose to buy the MacBook or
the iPad pro to build a website for a
small business or literally anything
else go to squarespace.com for a free
trial and use our custom link below when
you're ready to launch - save 10% on
your first purchase of a website or
domain now getting into the featured
differences between the two the iPad
pros display is not only brighter than
the one on the MacBook Air but it's also
more color accurate with p-3 wide color
gamut support so it's a much better
choice for photo or video editing which
we'll get into in just a minute the iPad
pro also has the massive benefit of pro
motion technology which allows the
display to dynamically adjust from 24 to
120 Hertz based on the content you're
viewing compared to the MacBook Airs
static 60 Hertz display this not only
makes it feel super fluid unless you
play certain games at 120 frames per
second but it greatly reduces the lag of
the Apple pencil for note-taking and
drawing something that you can't get on
the MacBook Air since it doesn't have a
touchscreen the iPad pro also uses face
ID to unlock which I prefer compared to
touch ID on the air now this next
feature doesn't really matter that much
but the FaceTime camera on the iPad pro
is much better than on the air just see
it for yourself this is a video and
audio quality tests on the 2019 MacBook
Air this is an audio and video quality
tests on the 2018 iPad pro on top of
that the iPad pro gets
the rear-facing camera for shooting 4k
videos however when comparing speakers
the MacBook Air sounds much better the
MacBook Air is also rated for 12 hours
of battery life compared to 10 on the
iPad pro and while both of them can
connect to external displays the air can
connect up to two of them now the
biggest difference between these two is
the performance in terms of processing
power the iPad pro completely blows the
macbook away in Geekbench v cpu test and
the story is the same for graphics
performance as well being so much more
powerful than the MacBook Air now while
this isn't an apples to apples
comparison since the software is
different the iPad pro truly does pack a
lot of performance and even though the
air is newer the iPad pro actually has
newer wireless specs like Bluetooth 5
and simultaneous dual-band Wi-Fi but on
the other hand the MacBook Air gets a
headphone jack which was ditched on the
2018 iPad pro the MacBook Air also gets
to Thunderbolt three ports which are
great for using superfast SSDs like a
custom SSD we built that's faster than
any other portable SSD we've ever seen
and you can check out that video at the
end of this one while it seems like a
downside for the iPad pro to only have
one USB C port there are now tons of
hubs available on Amazon that give the
iPad pro a bunch of extra ports and with
that let's get into the biggest
difference between these two computers
software support while the iPad pro does
get Mouse support it doesn't get a
cursor like you get with Mac OS on the
MacBook Air this is so much more
convenient for file management and
basically anything else but of course
the MacBook doesn't get touchscreen
support so that's a huge win for the
iPad the biggest deal is that there are
a lot of apps for Mac OS like Final Cut
Pro 10 Logic Pro 10 and Xcode and you
just can't get those apps on the iPad
however there are a lot of new
alternatives for the iPad that have
recently been getting a lot better for
photo editors we now have many photo
editing apps including the full version
of Adobe Lightroom and Photoshop right
on the iPad pro in Photoshop has
recently received a major update adding
a brand new object selection tool that
greatly increases productivity on the
iPad
they've also finally added a bunch of
typesetting features for the iPad as
well which is great for designers in
Lightroom has recently been updated to
finally add splitview support on the
iPad for video editors luma Forge has
recently been updated with a new Final
Cut Pro XML export feature this is
incredibly useful because it allows you
to do your basic cutting and editing on
your iPad pro while on the go before
exporting it to an XML file which you
can then open up on your Mac to add the
final finishing touches and plugins for
those who use apps like Word Excel and
PowerPoint Microsoft Office has recently
been released which combines those three
apps into one using less storage space
and coming with new mobile features so
far the excellent ratings show that it
works incredibly well especially since
they recently added split view support
for those of you into stock trading the
Robin Hood app for iOS has recently been
updated with new mobile features making
it easier to trade stocks Facebook has
also recently released their new creator
studio app allowing users to easily
manage their page content right on their
iPad the SoundCloud app for iOS now
integrates with the files app making it
easier to upload tracks right from your
iPad the Gmail app is adding files app
integration as well so you can add
attachments directly from the files app
instead of just the camera rolled the
ferrite recording studio app has also
added new features for iPad OS
Microsoft's project X cloud streaming
game service is now available for
testing on iOS as well
Microsoft is also working on bringing
their antivirus app to iOS sometime this
year and to be honest this is only the
beginning of the trend to add more
software support for the iPad so if you
choose the iPad pro over the MacBook it
will only get better over time
especially when Apple releases the next
version of iPad Wes now a lot of people
will argue that these alternatives just
aren't the same as apps like Logic Pro
10 and
Final Cut Pro but to be honest the
people who use those professional apps
should be buying the MacBook Pro instead
of the air for much better performance
the MacBook Air is meant for basic
computing tasks like web browsing video
streaming typing documents and working
with apps like Microsoft Excel and you
can do all of those things on the iPad
pro maybe even better than on the
MacBook plus you get Apple pencil
support so you can easily sign and
markup documents the iPad pro gets
access to the massive ios app store
filled with tons of games that you just
can't get or even run smoothly on the
macbook air but on the other hand the
macbook gets cursor support what you
just can't get on the iPad pro or at
least not yet so if this video helps you
make a purchasing decision we'll have
links down below for both the iPad pro
and the macbook air as well as the
bridge pro keyboard case and if you're
not already subscribed click the circle
above to do so right now thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]